bittersweet moment watching kyle winning
championship uh watching the city that
you love winning championship
but yet at the same time flipping on
your phone and seeing
people say well demar left and kawhi
came in and that's why they won take me
through that
shoulder
[Music]
man hbo max partnering sponsoring chips
that's love check this out
[Music]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
what's to become of our world
are you part of this family or not
the revolution will be televised
up everybody welcome back to chips you
know when doing a show like this i think
the most fun part for me is when i'm
able to have
friends of mine on so i'm welcoming a
special guest today my brother
demar derozan what's up brother what's
up dawg i appreciate you for having me
there were many
stories linking you to lebron linking
you to the lakers
uh then i saw something link you to the
clippers and ultimately
you know i had said in my mind like
there's a high possibility you know you
you may want to go back home
uh
most importantly just to be close to
moms obviously
uh with
pops passing away which you know
again sorry for the loss i know that's
tough i can't imagine
um
ultimately you decided to go
to chicago why did you end up saying all
right you know what i'm not doing that
um was it
those two teams didn't have the right
amount of money was it you just saw an
opportunity in chicago what was yeah i
mean it was it was a real possibility um
i mean i'd be lying to you if i didn't
say i wanted to come home you know
did try to make it happen there's a real
possibility on it happening um you know
just things didn't work out you know
what i mean but
you know um
chicago was always
in my top five that was always on my
radar you know what i mean and
you make the move to get lonzo
great pickup
been a fan of his and and
you see the narrative change with zach
when they stay if i came and obviously
vote boost there and you know we just
build off that to where it's like all
right this thing will be really be a
possibility then on the back end of it
it's a hell of a city
hell of a city absolutely a hell of an
organization to where like you get this
thing winning here
it's it's
come on let's talk about the journey uh
start you know growing up and compton
just take me back to those days and
how did compton shape who you are today
um i mean obviously growing up in the
environment you grew up in no matter how
bad or how good the situation may be
growing up in it you think it's normal
you know you try to be a kid as long as
you can but it kind of forced you to
grow up quick the city built me made me
resilient at the same time gave me an
imagination i want to do something
bigger than just
be in a neighborhood
you're still back there all the time
you're still showing
love to to where you come from and
i mean you're you're essentially still
just one of the guys for me
i remember being a kid and i remember
seeing like uh
a terrible nba player like the the 15
guy on the roster i remember seeing him
at a young age in l.a and felt like i
just seen jesus christ
it gave me hope and it gave a lot of
people around me hope so for me i always
just try to go back and just be normal a
lot of times not even be on some
preaching stuff just to be around just
to be around you had opportunities to go
play in other places further outside of
l.a probably to oak hill or anywhere
else why was it so important to you
to stay home and go to your public high
school um
i'd be lying
lying to you if i told you like i wasn't
scared to leave home like i was scared
of [ __ ] like
i was terrified you know what i mean
because like this this was all i knew
you know i mean family friends
everything i couldn't imagine going to
oak hill you know what i mean i was
terrified you know i mean then secondly
it was like
man this is where i'm from my high
school is terrible you know it's down
the street from my house i walk there
it's a terrible school to go to
but
it was just the challenge of me
saying like man let me go here and just
try to make something out of it it's
funny as hell to hear you sit here and
say i was terrified to leave
compton most people are terrified to go
to compton right yeah then you can go to
any college in america
and you decide to go to usc you know usc
is usc
but even at the time you were leaving to
go there it wasn't viewed as a
basketball powerhouse and you could have
went anywhere why usc
same reason
same reason bro i was terrified to leave
home
and the crazy thing with that even when
i went to usc i had such a culture shock
my first three months in college i still
was living in campus really i still was
back and forth you know how far is that
25 minutes okay you know what i mean i
still was back and forth because i was
just the culture shock was just
completely
something i couldn't like adjust to you
know what i mean so
that just goes back to me just being
terrified to leave home you know what i
mean so
as a as a kid
essentially 18 19 years old
heading into the draft
it's possible you can end up in michigan
you could end up in florida
louisiana
not only do you end up far away from
l.a you end up in another country
completing another country bro take me
there take me
drive night getting driving to toronto
what's the first thing that go to yo go
through your mind i didn't have a
passport i didn't have none of this [ __ ]
threw me off like damn nobody i know has
a passport you go through draft night
you get to draft night you get drafted
by toronto and you still don't have a
passport that passport two days before
the draft wow
to go to toronto i remember going up
there by myself the next morning to go
to toronto
i'm seeing
[ __ ] in the airport in french
i'm like
i'm like losing it you know you know how
it is yeah like
they go to like the whole culture shock
all over again you know what i mean and
this time around it's somewhere where i
can't just go home you know what i mean
i didn't have nobody with me i was by
myself
i remember bro i was still wearing
chucks in the wintertime i didn't know
how to dress you know everything coming
to the cold i've never been to the cold
i've never been to the car
nobody there to really teach me i'm the
only rookie on the team
so it ain't like i got somebody i can
hang with at all times and blah blah
blah so
it was a it was a shock you know what i
mean and luckily at one point jared jack
took me in
and really helped me
get through my rookie year him chris
bosh um reggie evans those guys really
took me in and kind of helped me because
bro i was i was lost for a minute you
know i mean i was lost what's so
interesting about that is most people
don't understand they hear you saying
like i gotta drive to toronto
but at that time 13 years ago toronto is
not what it is today
so you walking through the airport
there's french signs
on the highway it's like it's very
americanized now today yes
yes but at that time it was tough bro i
ain't gonna lie it was it was
it was the toughest time that was
necessary for me because i i hadn't
really
been snatched away to be like huh figure
it out you know i mean i always had that
crutch to go back home and be back home
so
my whole entire year i was by myself i
didn't have family with me nothing like
i was by myself figuring it out you
signed a new deal four years 38 million
and at that time by the way at that time
four years 38 is a lot of money in the
nba a lot during that same time you
signed the same amount of stuff
todd lawson yeah who else what drew
holiday
um
a lot of y'all at the same time signed
like the same deal yeah yeah and that's
when that was a lot of money in the nba
that's life-changing money yeah
how did you adapt to that for me it was
more so like
just
not
like i wanted to be
respected as a player not
by
the amount
of money that i'm getting you know what
i mean and i think
when that happened i kind of
had a different type of chip on my
shoulder it pushed me to a different
type of level to where like damn the
money
now i just got to step up to another
level you know what i mean like i got
that i'm not even worried about that i'm
not even speaking on that i just wanted
to be the player and be respected by my
peers
on the court we fast forward a little
bit
time in toronto
leading scorer breaking many records
all-star
all that which is by the way people
don't understand you know there's the
documentary on vince carter and how
that helped
grow toronto basketball
but then you come right after that and
building everything up
being the cornerstone of the franchise
you meet your best friend kyle lari
y'all did great things in toronto
expecting to keep building and keep
going up
and then
you're traded eventually
how did you feel about that process and
where did that take you with the game of
basketball um with the whole process it
was like
you know you
my whole mindset was to build
toronto up to be a respected team
because i played my first couple years
[ __ ] usually come in there
especially on the weekend games and be
like
you know
[ __ ] we going out night before we
playing the raptors at one o'clock on a
sunday
that's a show when we out all night
we win you know what i mean like teams
used to come in with that mentality so
for me
it was always personal like i wanted us
to be respected the organization be
respected the city be respected
when a situation happened to me just
getting traded
it hurt it hurt like [ __ ] because
you know my whole mindset was like yo
i'm riding i'm riding and dying like
like
only way i don't accomplish what i'm
trying to accomplish here if if if it's
on a stretcher that was my mentality so
when it happened it
it hit me hard you know what i mean like
a lot of people
always think like you know i was bitter
i was this and all this like nah it
[ __ ] me up because people don't know
how much
i had put into it you know the
conversations i had with players with
coaches the long nights the long days
playing through all type of [ __ ] you
know what i mean so
i don't know how much
better on and off the court
you could get it find an individual
that's gonna give it they all you know
what i mean like i didn't care about the
politics i didn't care about all it was
about was
the fans and basketball but it it it
taught me a valuable lesson of the
business that we in you know i mean that
we all expendable at some point you know
what i mean but we only have a short
window to do what we do you know it's
only a handful of guys that could
control their whole destiny through
their whole career you know i mean and i
read
before
that right before that or something
you met with messiah or
talked with messiah he told you you
weren't trading how long
between your conversation and you're
getting traded two days two days two
days
um
it was two days i went to vegas
we all met we had it have a [ __ ]
dinner you know have a sit down and have
a conversation about like all right
we bout to do this thing
we're about to give it one more shot
blah blah blah and two ladies later you
get a call
that was the [ __ ] that hurt
like tell me beforehand like look it's a
possibility we think about doing this
cool you know what i mean and your call
come from who messiah he tell you
traitor yeah he calls me so one i'm in a
movie theater to this day i do not watch
this movie right once this equalizer
took
my phone keep ringing
it's my size i'm like what the [ __ ]
so he texted me and said deebo give me a
call when you get a chance so i'm like
all right cool so as soon as i send the
text back i get on the ground
like i don't see nothing on the ground
i'm on twitter i'm googling [ __ ] so i'm
like all right i don't see like you know
it's just in my mind so
i laid a movie did i get in the car
called him back he didn't answer i'm
like all right probably ain't nothing
he called me back
and
he just you know asked how was the movie
like some casual [ __ ] you know what i
mean like something like movies cool
like yeah what's up she was like yeah
we just traded you to san antonio i just
want to let you know it's going to come
out in the morning
and i was like
literally bro
i i i touched the driver
i just stopped the car
i got off the car and just walked down
the street hung up the phone
sat outside
a jack-in-the-box or dell taco for like
two hours that's what i got
that's what i got i called two people i
called kyle
he was he was shocked about it he didn't
know
then i caught
i called rudy and told him like yo i
just got traded he said to weird i said
san antonio
he started laughing right
i'm like [ __ ] you and hung on the phone
like
you want to laugh well [ __ ] it but you
know what i mean but it was it was it
was one of the toughest times
ever because
i didn't really have like no guidance
with this [ __ ] you know what i mean like
nobody helped me like and i like me i
and i i wasn't going to talk to nobody
about it you know what i mean i was just
i just wanted to take it all in and
figure it out as it went you know i mean
but it was tough it was tough
with you leaving the raptors kawhi going
to the raptors
it feels very similar to us
and steve kerr and mark jackson mm-hmm
you know whereas like
there's always this question of
well if mark was still there
which
the year he got fired we won a
championship would they have won a
championship
and there's no right or wrong answer
if you were still there
and kawhi is still in san antonio does
the raptors end up in that same position
bittersweet moment watching kyle winning
a championship
uh watching the city that you love
winning championship
but yet at the same time flipping on
your phone and seeing
people say well demar left and kawhi
came in and that's why they won take me
through that
it was definitely a part of me
you know
feeling the way i'd be you know be lying
and it was a part of me saying like
you know those guys out there is my
partners he's my brothers like cal
freddy pascal
o.g
like norm all those guys on that team
was my dogs like you know what i mean we
was
we was like that and i stayed in
constant communication with him you know
i mean
and everyone to tell you like after
every game if it was a good game or a
bad game i was the first one to hit him
you know what i mean
but
at the same time you know you you don't
want to look at [ __ ]
social media wise because
everything was in a comparison of like
oh
demar wouldn't it did this all right but
this week you know what i mean
everything that was happening it was
frustrating because i kept getting
pulled into it you know i mean so once
it gets to the finals just like oh demar
never could get them to the finals
this this and that whole narrative was
just frustrating to where it was like
all right damn social media so by the
time they got to the finals i think i
end up like
leaving out the country and just getting
away from everything and everybody in my
phone i'm happy to this day like i'm
happy for the city i'm happy for
you know um for those guys that wanted
and everything but you know of course
that was my my goal was to be the one to
make make that happen you know what i
mean but
you know like
is what it is does do you feel
because of the way that played out
because they went on to win the
championship
do you feel more pressure
to win a championship now
for you um i wouldn't necessarily say
more pressure like i feel the same
because you know at the end of the day
like my ultimate goal is
to win one but you know
it's crazy because whether they want it
every time somebody wanted you know [ __ ]
when y'all want it like my relationship
with you was like damn my dog got a ring
he got touring you got three like you
know what i mean like same with clay
like
people that i could go back
and look at like where we came from it's
like you got rings so it's like you know
you want to be part of that group of
guys you know what i mean like that's
the end goal you know what i mean so
whether they want it or not like my my
every year it feels
like he needed more like [ __ ] we don't
play this [ __ ] forever you know i mean
yeah it's like once you get it out the
way it's like all right cool you can
breathe now you know what i mean yeah
facts for shows you know me but when you
like damn it's my 13th year i ain't got
one
what's going on you know what i mean so
so in dealing with all of this you've
been very outspoken about mental health
where is it now have you have you seen
changes in in the way people are
operating with it is it kind of the same
is it still a
for you know unthought of thing in the
league where is that now
in in the progression since you first
start speaking on it the the
conversation in the topic in a narrative
is definitely a priority
so with that being a priority it
definitely made so much progress because
before then you know especially in our
sport it was never talked about you know
nobody never talked about the situation
that we all
have for one
we come into the league with so much
trauma that we don't even identify with
from our childhood you know what i mean
but we suppress it and forget about it
so easy because all of a sudden now
we're rich
but now with us all of a sudden getting
money now we have a new set of problems
yeah we haven't even
uncovered the whole
[ __ ] we went through 20 years prior you
know i mean now we forced to be in a
spotlight
have fame have money have attention and
have even more temptations and more
problems that come with that that we
gathering
more
[ __ ] [ __ ] that
like will build up unconsciously
and you will see outbursts or certain
you know
reactions from people and you wonder why
at our age bro like
we was taught to
be tough absolutely you know what i mean
[ __ ] powers do everything yeah like
man [ __ ] all that [ __ ] you going through
you you got to get through this [ __ ]
ain't no crying you better suck it up
and keep going you know what i mean like
but you know we both fathers now and you
see the difference
on how to be with your own children
because you know [ __ ] that's not
necessarily the right way yeah i mean
yeah that's not the right way and my
biggest thing is
just having players in our position
share stories that they with through
because that [ __ ] is inspiring to
the next generation you know what i mean
it's a different type of
you know
inspiration that you give and confidence
and that you give that
you know
these kids knowing that it's okay you
know what i mean okay you gon you're
gonna go through this but now identify
with it and understand it so you don't
fall victim to
you know
the aggression and wondering why you had
this aggression or this hatred or this
or your confidence not there or your
insecurities and all this stuff that
could come with it mental health does
not discriminate on nobody
in life you know what i mean and
i realized that
as black man we always felt like we was
in competition with one another like i'm
not about to let you know what i'm going
through yeah for what like you probably
use that against me you know what i mean
instead of understanding like what's
going on bro like and just
bounce off conversation and realize how
much [ __ ] you could get off each other's
chests that
tomorrow you're going to take a
different approach with something that
you normally do that bothers you and
approach it the right way to get through
it easier you know what i mean
absolutely nike recently gave every nike
employee i think a week off um
and
it was centered around their mental
health like everybody take a week
and kind of gather yourself recharged we
saw an instance like that last season um
where kyrie essentially went on a hiatus
i think it was maybe seven to ten days
of where he's like no i'm just not
mentally in a good place and i need to
step away from basketball
is that something that the nba need like
similar to what nike just did because
you know we get all-star break right but
number one if you're an all-star it's
not a break not a break do you see that
as something that's coming to the league
that need to be in the league as someone
who has
struggled with mental health do we need
a mental health week
yeah and i think
that comes with a conversation of action
what guys need everybody needs something
differently you know i mean like for me
my hooping is my therapeutic belief you
know i mean sometimes i i just want to
be out there who you know what i mean
like
like and be around that type of
environment you know what i mean that's
that's that's for me some people may be
different to it like i just need to step
away and not see a basketball for you
know a certain amount of days you know i
mean i think that's a conversation that
should be had around
people who who understand
what they need so they don't fall
in that in that black hole
what is
the happiest
you've been playing basketball
basketball
it's always made me happy just that
opportunity to play honestly bro i never
take it for granted bro and it's like
just knowing where i came from just
knowing that i'm i'm able to be in a
lead this long
like that's my happy place it's one day
we gonna have to hang this [ __ ]
fast so every time i get a chance to
play it's like yo this
you got to enjoy it you got to enjoy it
how much longer you want to go
for sure not know 20 years i ain't
trying to play no 20. i can't do 20. you
know i ain't trying to hey
i i don't know bro i don't you want to
put a number on it but
20 is a long time i definitely don't
want to be playing at 40. i want to be
40 years old still playing i come in
vince and
all the guys who played today was 40. i
i just don't think mentally or
physically i want to do it
hey i appreciate you coming out man i
appreciate you coming on the show as my
brother it's always special
um to sit down and have these
conversations i don't take this for
granted i take it extremely serious i'm
very appreciative thank you for coming
on man always
chips that's a wrap
[Music]